bonsoir nous sommes le 7 novembre
nouvelle édition du Journal de la
rédaction le 78 lactu comme chaque soir
à 18h en direct et ce soir il sera
question des élections à honcour
politique Parti socialiste et Parti
communiste les deux formations se sont
rapprochées dans le cadre des
municipales une conférence de presse
commune vient de se tenir hier soir le
haut débit pour la ville de plaisir
c'est pour demain l'opérateur Orange a
présenté son dispositif avec l'appui de
la municipalité et puis à la veille du
100e anniversaire de la guerre de 1418
une vaste opération de collecte
d'archives s'organise je recevrai la
chef de service aux archives
départementales des ivelines ainsi que
une archiviste de la mairie de
guillancour pour en parler et puis
restez bien avec nous à la fin de ce
journal vous entendrez axel Bauer il est
actuellement en répétition à la batterie
à Guill en courour avant son passage sur
scène dans la
soirée l'image du jour c'est la filière
équestre mobilisée contre la hausse de
la TVA annoncé au 1er janvier qui
pourrait passer de 7 à 20 % une
opération escargo était organisée ce
jeudi matin entre Saint-Germain en Laet
et Rambouillet en passant par Versailles
et plaisir à l'initiative d'un collectif
là hors de 78 qui rassemble des
professionnels des éleveurs des
cavaliers ou encore des professeurs sur
la route pour cette première
manifestation une douzaine de voitures
la hausse de la TV de 7 à 20 % est exigé
par Bruxelles pour harmoniser les taux
en Europe coup dur pour ces
professionnels qui rappellent qu'il ne
disposeent d'aucune subvention publique
et on n'oublie pas que les Yvelines sont
le premier département francilien en
matière d'activité
équestre là le risque c'est queavec une
hausse de 13 points d'un coup on puisse
pas survivre si on la répercute pas sur
les clients et d'un autre côté si les
clients c'est même pas sûr qu'il nous
suivent et on serait la seule
coopération à subir une hausse aussi imp
importante de TVA donc puisque
l'industrie du libre notamment est
toujours à 55 si je si je m'abuse
actuellement moi je suis dans une
pension au prêt donc je paye 200 € par
cheval et donc bah ça va faire une
énorme augmentation que pour le moment
j'avoue je n'ai pas calculé parce que ça
fait très peur une augmentation de TVA
pour Lesens les gens particuliers comme
moi qui ont une pension c'est une chose
mais ça va clairement fermer des centres
é caisses puisque le prix des cours va
augmenter quand on voudra prendre une
carte à l'année ça va faire un énorme
changement
le prix des pensions également vont
augmenter donc petit à petit ça va faire
fermer du monde ça va je pense
honnêtement diriger de plus en plus de
gens vers des particuliers et du coup ça
va pas du tout servir la filière
professionnelle les Franciliens les
professionnels franciliens qui reste
mobilisé manifestation prévu par le
comité régional d'équitation lundi 11
novembre en valdarne ainsi que les 18 et
19 novembre prochain dans la France
entière à en courour les socialistes et
les communistes réunis sur la même liste
pour les élections mun Mpal le PC a
finalement décidé de ne pas se présenter
avec ses alliés du Front de gauche le
Parti de Gauche notamment une conférence
de presse vient de se tenir chacun
revendique sa liberté d'expression mais
le mot d'ordre est commun se montrer uni
face au maire sortant l'UMP Jean Michel
Fourgous il est question aussi de faire
barrage au Front National qui se
présentera c'est une nouveauté dans la
ville le programme est en cours
d'élaboration il est question du social
de dialogue avec la population on écoute
la tête de liste Michel bessau suivi du
représentant du PCF nous parle des
raisons de ce
rapprochement parce que nous estimons
que l'union fait la force et que sur a
priori le nombre de listes qu'il y aura
sur H encour 4 5 je n'en sais rien pour
le moment mais en tout cas il n'y en a
qu'une seule à gauche la droite est
divisée et nous nous avons souhaité
partir unis pour donner une nouvelle
impulsion à l'alliance avec le Parti
communiste est aussi un signe fort de la
part des des représentants de la gauche
en disant mais le gouvernement a
peut-être failli sur certains points ou
ne va peut-être pas assez loin sur
certains points et nous localement nous
voulons une véritable politique de
gauche en 2008 nous avions déjà un
accord avec le Parti socialiste et le
fait d'avoir travaillé ensemble et nous
semble-t-il dans de bonnes conditions
fait que nous repartons ensemble pour
2014 car comme je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure pour nous l'essentiel c'est de
changer de cap et Michel Michel bessau
sera le prochain invité de municipal
2014 mardi prochain le rendez-vous
politique de TV fil en direct des
18h30 la pluie ne devrait pas être un
problème pour les cyclistes un inventeur
des Essards le roi a mis en place un
dispositif antipluie vous allez le voir
une invention originale que vous allez
découvrir en image avec Claire Cambier
et Jonathan
villman sur la selle de ce vélo Arnaud
Sarfati ne manque pas d'attirer les
regards cet inventeur nous présente ici
son dispositif anti-pluie et antiffroid
spécial cycliste habitué du de roues
Arnaud en avait assez d'être mouillé
après un an de recherche il pense avoir
trouvé la solution un projet fou je
pense que la folie l'inconscience c'est
un peu le propre des chefs d'entreprise
des créateurs c'est-à-dire que oui ça
fait peur mais euh
euh derrière chaque porte on voit
d'autres choses et tant qu'on a pas
franchi la première porte quand on crée
une entreprise on sait pas ce qu'il y a
derrière et donc l'idée c'est euh il y a
il y a une part de folie et
d'inconscience j'en suis conscient mais
euh si on ne se lance pas euh on sait
jamais si ça peut aboutir cet ingénieur
n'en est pas à sa première création il y
a plus de 10 ans il lance un des sites
leader de covoiturage en 2012 il vend
cette société c'est aujourd'hui le début
d'une nouvelle aventure pour arriver à
mettre au point susistème antipluie
Arnaud a commencé par réaliser
différents prototypes tout a commencé
chez lui aux zessardleroi donc là je
suis dans mon garage j'ai fait beaucoup
de pièces avec avec quelques outils donc
un étau un poste à soudure
une paire de pince et puis du du fil de
métal en plus des structures métalliques
il fallait imaginer une tente une
couturière voile l'a aidé puis il a fait
appel à des industriels pour la
construction une quinzaine de prototypes
ont été réalisés avant d'arriver au
projet final alors comment ça marche
explication en image première étape la
pose des armatures donc le principe
c'est que ça se monre très simplement et
sans outil en fait c'est ça ensuite on
installe la toile différents modèles
existe pour s'adapter aux différents
vélos existants VTT de ville et même
pliable des crochets permettent à la
tente d'être tenu et deux baguettes
maintiennent la structure du dispositif
1,50 de long pour 1 M10 de hauteur voilà
donc là il est prêt à partir pour se
faire connaître il se balade en ville
protégée du Rouby et raconte ses
aventures sur son blog ce créateur
propose dès aujourd'hui ses différents
modèles en quatre coloris compté 98 €.
il a reçu une dizaine de commandes et
compte s'attaquer au pays nordies j'ai
développé deux pages une en allemand une
en anglais pour que le site internet
réponde aussi au référencement dans les
différentes langues et qui soit visible
donc il est accessible par ces
différents pays avec un investissement
de 100000 € Arnaud espère atteindre
l'équilibre d'ici 2 à 3
ans d'ici 2020 une centaine de communes
des Eveline devrait pouvoir bénéficier
d'un accès à la fibre optique 10 à 20
fois plus rapide que l'actuel ADSL par
ces communes celle de plaisir le
chantier a démarré en 2012 Catherine
zulato Jonathan
villman la fibre optique on en parle
beaucoup mais peu l'utilise encore pour
cause sur le département son déploiement
a été lancé en 2010 par Orange et SFR
pour couvrir d'ici 2020 une centaine de
communes ce qui représente pour vous
donner quelques repères 83 % des
logements qui seront donc déployés par
l'initiative privé dans le département
la fibre optique a été déployée sur le
secteur de Saint-Germain en la et des
boucles de scène plaisir fait partie des
20 premières communes fibrées 50 % des
logements peuvent potentiellement y
accéder on a trois critères on va dire
il y a un critère de de densité un
critère technique en fonction des
équipements des centraux téléphoniques
et puis on va en priorité dans des
communes dans des quartiers de communes
où le réseau ADSL apporte un débit le
plus faible enfin le plus faible le
déploiement de la fibre sur la ville de
Plaisir devrait s'achever d'ici
2015-27 l'ensemble des habitants et des
entreprises pourront profiter d'un
réseau 10 à 20 fois plus rapide que la
dsl de quoi intéresser ceux qui veulent
utiliser de nouveaux services comme la
télé en 3D télécharger ou envoyer des
fichiers très lourds un défi stratégique
pour les communes qui espèrent ainsi
attirer des entreprises à fortes demande
technologique économique pour les
opérateurs qui investissent de Lourdes
sommes 2 milliards d'euros rien que pour
Orange pour l'ensemble du
territoire hier mercredi avait lieu la
présentation officielle des 20 projets
candidats au solar Décathlon 2014 cette
compétition universitaire mondiale
réunissant 16 pays s'établira pour la
première fois en France à Versailles en
juin prochain l'objectif imaginer la
maison du futur qui serait uniquement
alimenté par l'énergie du soleil Anthony
rche et le di moine les 20 équipes
candidates au solar d'cathlon 2014 ont
enfin dévoilé leur prototype rien à voir
avec une course de voiture ici
l'objectif est de concevoir une maison
ou un habitat uniquement alimenté par
l'énergie solaire l'enjeu est double car
le concept proposé doit avoir un coût
acceptable avec une enveloppe de départ
de 100000 € fixée par l'organisation le
projet nanté Phileas veut réintroduire
la production agricole dans un bâtiment
d'une superficie de 70 m car pour un
budget final de 400000 € le projet
global c'est de réhabiliter ce bâtiment
là en introduisant une ferme pédagogique
une une ser en en haut du bâtiment et
comme vous pouvez le voir sur le
prototype qu'on emmène à Versailles on a
a reproduit la serre la trium cette
cette idée de nature au sein du au sein
même du bâtiment chaque équipe a pour
mission de concevoir construire faire
fonctionner et même déconstruire un
projet de bâtiment de demain ils doivent
répondre à un cahier des charges très
précis le logement conçu doit par
exemple intégrer des services de
transport et plutôt être collectif ce
qui est très intéressant c'est une
réflexion pas c'est pas une petite boîte
qui construise c'est à travers cette
maison écologique
une réflexion sur l'urbanité en général
et vous voyez combien toutes les équipes
insist sur la pris en compte de leur
problématique nationale l'équipe
chilienne présentera un habitat
d'urgence post tremblement de terre et
les Roumains le projet de réhabilitation
total d'un immeuble stalinien des années
70 rendez-vous à Versailles le 28 juin
prochain pour l'étape finale dans le
parc du château et les visites des
projet grandeur
nature on passe à l'entretien de cette
édition du 7 novembre je reçois en
plateau Mathilde d'uve bonsoir vous êtes
responsable des publics aux archives
départementales des Yvelines et face à
vous Isabelle Gourmelin bonsoir
archiviste en mairie de guillancour
François Hollande vient de lancer cet
après-midi les commémorations du
centenaire de la Grande Guerre de 1418
il a évoqué les valeurs de la nation de
la République un discours pour inaugurer
un cycle important de commémoration on a
le sentiment que ce conflit de 1418
passionne les Français est-ce que vous
en tant que archiviste vous avez le même
sentiment oui oui vraiment je pense que
enfin la grande collecte commence à
réveiller un petit peu les réactions de
nos ivelinois puisque de notre côté on
prépare depuis un certain temps la
semaine prochaine la grande collecte
effectivement on reçoit déjà beaucoup
d'appel dans cadre de cette série de
commémoration voilà qui est une collecte
nationale hein et auquelle bah participe
le Conseil Général des Yveline bien sûr
en partenariat avec la Bibliothèque
nationale de France la la mission
centenaire les Archives de France et la
Bibliothèque nationale de France et
différentes municipalités également
comme agui en cours com comment on peut
l'expliquer ce le fait que les Français
soient si passionnés par ce conflit vous
avez une explication ça se traduit dans
les romans dans au cinéma il y a des
documentaires il faut pas oublier que
c'est quand même ça a été un toutes les
familles de France ont été touchées par
ce par ce ce drame et chaque famille
justement a des trésors a envie de
témoigner parce que c'est encore une
génération qui se souvient qui a eu
grand-père grand grand-mère touché de
d'une façon ou d'une autre par ce cet
épisode dramatique oui on a envie VI les
différents objets de ce souvenir
puisquil n'y a plus de témoins direct
c'est difficile donc forcément c'est à
travers tous ces objets d'où
l'importance de votre travail dans les
différentes archives on va en parler
dans un instant juste après ce micro
trottoir que savez-vous de la Grande
Guerre justement vos
réponses qu'elle a été très mortelle
et terrible terrible les tranchés les
c'est surtout qu'elle a fait beaucoup de
morts la plus meurtrière c'est
l'armistice qui a eu lieu le 11 novembre
ça a été la la première confrontation
avec l'aviation aussi les anciens qu'on
combattu pour la France donc faut garder
le souvenir un petit peu boucherie les
poilu et une période quand même de
beaucoup beaucoup de morts mon
grand-père a été fait prisonnier pendant
la grande guerre en Allemagne ça faisait
beaucoup de dégâts et on est bien
content de ne plus connaître à à nos
jours et dans le cadre de ces
commémorations des 100 ans du début de
la grande guerre on le disait tout à
l'heure et donc lancer une grande
collecte pas uniquement en France
d'ailleurs c'est à travers toute
l'Europe même que c'est mené cela
débutera officiellement le 12 novembre
jusqu'au 16 novembre si vous disposez de
documents d'attente de cette période
vous pourrez les confier aux archives de
votre département pour les numériser
pour l'instant vous avez beaucoup de de
mondes qui se sont manifestés quel type
de documents quelles sont les les
sources de cette période alors tous les
documents personnels peuvent nous
intéresser hein je peux dire que ça peut
partir de la carte postale la lettre
d'un grand-père un carnet de voyage une
photographie ça peut même être un objet
éventuellement voilà on est prêt à
accueillir tout type d'objets et je
voudrais préciser que ce sont pas
uniquement des objets qui concerneraient
typiquement le département on accueille
bien sûr tout témoignage de la guerre
quel que soit le front que ça concerne
quel que soit le département que
çaartementcoup de population qui
viennent de l'ensemble de la France
forcément vous devez avoir des gens qui
se manifestent avec des des richesses
d'autres d'autres régions sur
guilloncour vous avez commencé déjà ce
travail de de collecte oui tout à fait
nous on est on a lancé notre appel dans
le guyoncour magazine sur le site de la
ville on a déjà des gens qui se sont
manifestés donc forcément on les on fait
le relais avec les archives
départementales on les réoriente et puis
il faut dire aussi que nous avons un
projet d'exposition donc à ce titre on
on on prend des contacts on essaie de
trouver des objets qui pourraient
illustrer le mieux possible notre
exposition qui aura lieu donc à
l'automne 2014 et pour les différents
documents qui sont collectés via les
archives il y a aussi une plateforme
internet mission centenaire 1418 qui
existe l'adresse va s'afficher voilà
alors on prévoit au mois de février
d'installer enfin de proposer en tout
cas à tous les Ives Linois de participer
à une plateforme collaborative sur
lesquel seront mis en valeur justement
tous ces documents qui ont été
recueillis lors de la la collecte la
semaine prochaine mais surtout tout au
long de de la commémoration en fait
parce que en dehors de cette semaine
spécifique de de collecte j'imagine que
vous recevez des documents tout au long
de l'année on pourra proposer en tout
cas à chaque aginois de participer et de
mettre en ligne des documents qui
pourrai intéresser cette période et en
fait ça sera pas uniquement sur l'année
2014 mais je dirais de 2014 à 2018 en
fait le département a été marqué de
quelle manière pendant cette grande
guerre alors là effectivement on n'est
pas je dirais qu'on a pas été impacté de
manière directe mais évidemment tout à
chacun a autour de lui quelqu'un dans sa
famille hein qui a participé à la guerre
je dirais que le département en
particulier a accueilli beaucoup de
réfugiés
euh de du Nord de la France de Belgique
voilà et euh également s'est instauré
toute une solidarité euh par exemple au
niveau des hôpitaux hein on le voit il y
a beaucoup de de grandes propriétés qui
ont servi à accueillir justement des
hôpitaux un petit peu de de fortune
pendant cette pendant cette période sur
guuill encour alors sur guuill encour
c'était il faut imaginer que c'était un
tout petit village hein il y avait même
une nouvelle l'agglomération n'était pas
là hein forc 700 habitants donc et bon
on a quand même eu 38 morts pour la
France sur 700 habitants et puis il y
avait des problématiques de village d'un
village rural au niveau de la
l'agriculture hein la main d'œuvre était
partie au front des effectivement
l'accueil des réfugiés des cantonnements
voilà comment la vie quotidienne devait
s'organiser euh c'était c'était rude
aussi à l'arrière peut-re voir quelques
photos quelques documents qui sont
extraits du fond des Archives
départementales certaines affiches par
exemple comme celle-ci c'est une affiche
de la mairie de Versailles qui invitait
les habitants join du clairon à se
mettre à disposition de la mairie ou
encore le parc de l'abaye du Mousseau
menils transformé en hôpital vous disiez
tout à l'heure certains sites qui
servaient d'hôpitaux justement vous avez
beaucoup de documents de de ce type là
beaucoup de cartes postales de photos on
a un certain nombre de cartes postales
effectivement on a des T témoignages qui
sont parfois témoignages poignant
vraiment qui pourrai s'approcher de
lettres de poilu par exemple on a des
lettres d'instituteur partis au front et
qui raconte vraiment le quotidien de des
tranchers on a bien sûr des documents
administratifs tels que les affiches que
vous avez vu tout à l'heure qui
présentent vraiment qui qui permettent
de se représenter justement la dureté de
cette vie à l'arrière cet effort cette
solidarité envers les soldats et le fond
Gén et puis il y a le site de saincir à
l'école également la base aéronautique
de saincir pé iquement qui abritait des
dirigeables durant la Première Guerre
mondiale un atelier employant près de
4000 personnes voilà une des photos qui
témoignent aussi de cette activité sur
le
département même chose lorsque les gens
viennent vous voir ils viennent aussi
pour prendre des informations en savoir
plus sur ce conflit et sur la manière
dont leur ville peut-être ou peut-être
même retrouver des des proches leur
familles qui ont participé au conflit
oui il y a énormément de recherches
autour de ce qu'on appelle les registres
matricules qui sont véritablement les
fiches militaires qui permettent de
retracer le parcours
de de de chaque soldat et puis bien sûr
on vient trouver tout tout
l'environnement de de la guerre on a
beaucoup de mande aussi du côté par
exemple des scolaires qui veulent
s'intéresser à cette période des
personnes qui font des recherches par
rapport à des noms qui apparaissent sur
des monuments aux morts voilà un peu
près l'essentiel de de des recherches
pour l'instant c'est mené de la même
manière AC guoncour j'imagine que vous
travaillez ensemble que les gens
viennent vous voir viennent aussi s ils
habitent sur la ville viennent vous voir
aussi tout à fait ce sont des sources
complémentaires Archiv communal Archiv
départemental et puis archive familiale
du coup ça permet effectivement de
retracer de recouper de pouvoir tracer
des destins retracer redessiner des
destins et c'est voilà c'est c'est très
riche et c'est c'est ça qu'on espère
avoir aussi des témoignages de Guillon
courtois ça serait formidable pour
l'instant vous n'en avez pas eu on en a
on a quelques descendants de familles de
soldats Guill en courtois donc on
aimerait là je fais un appel vraiment on
aimerait en avoir plus ça serait
formidable est-ce que vous avez réussi à
travers ces différentes sources à
collectter des objets des casques des
choses comme ça euh oui oui alors il y a
des personnes qui se sont manifestées
qui effectivement on des casques on
peuvent avoir une gourde peu avoir voilà
du grand-père
ououi il y aura des objets et ça c'est
c'est c'est c'est c'est intéressant
aussi ce sont des objets qu'on vous
confie ou que vous prenez en photo et
que vous restiuez après parce qu'il y a
peut-être aussi on va peut-être lever
une crainte des gens qui se disent ou là
si je dis que j'ai des archives chez moi
on va venir me les prendre je voudrais
les garder ce sont des trésors de
famille absolument faut lever cette
crainte en fait tout sera conf prêter le
temps de la numérisation qui va être
fait aux archives départementales ou de
la prise de vue éventuellement si pour
des certains objets et tout sera rendu
hein il y a pas de souciz oui oui sauf
si les personnes bien
se ah ouià on pas contre non plus merci
donc à toutes les deux d'être venu
parler de cette grande collecte dans le
cadre descendant du début de la grande
guerre on va juste revoir les
différentes adresses si les gens
souhaitent vous contacter aussi bien aux
archives municipales qu'aux Archives
départementales et puis je le rappelle
he le 11 novembre sera marqué par les
commémorations de fin du conflit dans
les différentes communes retour dans ce
journal à présent sur une histoire
survenue à un ancien salarié de la MGEN
sur le site de La Verrière depuis peu le
parc qui appartient à la mutuelle de
l'éducation nationale a donc étaé cédé à
la ville pour que le public puisse s'y
promener des grillages ont été installés
pour des raisons de sécurité seulement
pour la demeure de l'ancien responsable
des jardins qui réside toujours aucune
porte de sortie n'a été prévue c'est
insolide mais pas forcément facile à
vivre au quotidien sa voiture est
bloquée dans son garage depuis plusieurs
semaines claire Cambier et l
moine depuis le 25 octobre Jean-Pierre
pevion ne peut plus sortir sa voiture de
son garage cette clôture construite sur
le côté de son habitation empêche tout
accès la raison de cette situation pour
le moins hubuesque l'ouverture au public
du parc du château à La Verrière car
cette maison se trouve à l'entrée du
parc pour la MGEN propriétaire des lieux
cette clôture est une question de
sécurité ce qui est important pour nous
c'est de maintenir la sécurité dans cet
espace qui est public et dans la
convention qui a été
rédigée en collaboration avec laakkii et
la mairie il est prévu l'absence de
circulation d'engin à moteur dans le
parc autre argument avancé empêcher
l'intrusion des Badeau sur le terrain de
Monsieur pevillon contacter la mairie de
La Verrière indique qu'une exception
peut être faite face à cette situation
et a même confié les clés de la grille
principale à Jean-Pierre pevion pour lui
laisser l'accès mais la situation est
plus compliquée qu'elle n'y paraît
monsieur pevion est l'ancien chef de
service des espaces verts du parc la
MGEN l'a employé durant 48 ans et cette
habitation était son logement de
fonction la société a externalisé cette
année l'entretien du parc à une
entreprise locale qui a conservé par
obligation légale les employés et repris
à sa charge ce logement ce changement de
statut a été mal vécu par l'ancien
salarié qui a par ailleurs entamé des
démarches contre la MGEN pour inégalité
de salaire j'ai revendiqué
monu enfin ce que je pense ce que je
pense être monu après on verra je ne
présage de
rien et il est évident que depuis les
relations se sont tendues une
conciliation devrait être organisé à ce
sujet en mars quant à la grille la MGEN
n'envisage pas pour le moment de créer
une
ouverture voilà pour l'histoire donc de
cet ancien salarié de la MG pour
terminer je vous le disais au début de
cette édition B est en répétition en ce
moment agui en cours à la batterie avant
un concert qu'il donnera ce soir
l'artiste révélé par Cargo de Nuit un de
ses succès en 1983 relancé aussi avec
éteint la lumière en 92 puis avec son
duo avec zasie en 2000 interprétera les
nouveaux titres de son album pot de
serpent serpent avec un S Aelia debicii
est allé le rencontrer j'ai voulu mettre
l'accent euh sur le le sur le les les
textes je voulais que chaque texte soit
vraiment le reflet de de de de ce que je
vis de ce que je ce que je ressens et
Cera je voulais être au plus proche de
ce que je je chantais cet album a
représenté une à la fois une rupture et
un changement avec ce que j'ai pu faire
en tout cas je je l'ai perçu comme ça
c'est toujours une continuité mais il y
a il y a une vraie renaissance pour moi
à travers cet album et donc j'ai pris la
métaphore du du serpent qui change de
peau pour rentrer dans dans sa nouvelle
peau sa nouvelle vie on va dire
symboliquement et puis aussi le le
l'écaille de de de
serpent est
souvent récupéré par le le le monde du
rock soit sur sur un bouson on se
rappelle de Nicolas Cage dans seller and
loua qui dit c'est le symbole de mon
identité ou alors sur des chaussures et
tout ça et là j'ai une guitare qui est
en pot de serpent bon pot de serpent
donc le nom de son album axel Bauer ce
jeudi soir en concert à 3 à la batterie
à Guill encour et il reste encore des
places c'est la fin de ce journal je
vous retrouve vendredi pour un nouveau
point complet sur l'actualité nous
reviendrons notamment sur le verdict du
procès concernant le mari de cette femme
voilée att trrappe dont le contrôle
mouvementé d'identité cet été avait
déclenché une série d'meutes ce soir sur
TV fil vous avez rendez-vous avec Claire
Cambier pour un nouveau numéro de
filecho bonne soirée et à
demain